welcome to this video playing the chest
lot just lured from Canada okay Kings
Indian okay playing did that play that
yes Queen 85 hard time to to remember
that's been a long time since I played
there Kings Indian in regular tournament
chess this was one of the lights that
are played he does not play d5 that's
bad news
yeah nowadays people know how to play
that it seems back in the day they all
play d5 this is really a bit
uncomfortable how do I play that maybe
now before can i play Queen a 6
I'd like to have some type of play but
it's a it's really uncomfortable if i
take now 95 okay let's do that or maybe
even see five I know it looks wacky and
c5 c5b should be three
see if I officially tree takes be for a
bee queen see form ciao looks very
weakening very very weakening 95 is
probably playing be 5v5 2550 that's not
so bad at least then this is also a bit
weakening for wide
night night to see 5 can be might be a
good idea interesting
look do you wanna didn't expect this
type of move to take him hmm
I still this is regrouping night ft 7 is
a physical f4 this is bit bit annoying
or kept I'm spending too much time 22
minutes 30 30 seconds the idea is to get
this to c5 using this weekend square
hmm yeah but the dark squares is
weakened the dark squares quite
substantially okay what about see for
now see for I've got to check here this
is what what I'm thinking about to see
form takes and then takes here yeah
probably should try to play as active as
possible yeah the Seaport it was a
passer but this is not too bad i think
attacking g3 and having the the Queen
active 23 maybe or is there some drastic
move okays got lucky 7 coming hmm
oh that's that's a problem
this wasn't this wasn't my intention at
all ah no now he's got the bishop him
hmm ok I'll try for come to play giving
up the poem and then tried to push with
g5 but yeah he's got he's got Bishop at
three after g5 hmm
what a game check okay at least this is
a pin check
yeah I it's it's not it's not I hope not
that easy because of the opposite
calendar shops the problem is I have
absolutely no time and okay of course
the position might be lost as well but
no time is also an issue 22 seconds
time warning
check
yeah give me time ten seconds what the
heck yeah of course the position check
also very bad check you know check know
the position is ok I think but the time
one second I am I just I just played it
far too slowly and not very good of the
last four cuts on time yeah oh my god ok
yeah what went wrong there i don't i
don't know i think around here i should
be I should be ok would be a good it was
surprised me if I'm ever in big trouble
I family don't think so hmm yeah this is
five moves awesome what's a problem
maybe this wasn't a bad a good idea
after all possible I mean II five is a
strong strong move it cuts my pieces off
from the action I was hoping to to have
some play on the dark squares yeah those
those kind of vague ideas to play let's
say I know it's not let's let's get go
here those vague ideas like it's a g5
yeah if he takes you should be fine yeah
and you have some some decent play but
this is
just just the problem I mean if you need
to play Luke f8 that this is utter crap
so I couldn't allow group d 7 and now
this is really really trouble you know I
try to give up the pawn right way to
generate counter pJAK but this is of
course very good for what I mean he
didn't play as technical face very well
at the end like was completely okay but
I just was hard to check too much behind
on the clock check check check at the
end I just want the porn it's just just
about equal but ok 0 seconds is not very
not very equal they have you have this
this line this line back in the day they
they all plate d 5 here in this position
lucky I they played d5 and then you had
this position ruka c8 and get this this
possible idea of exchanging the bad
bishop this is quite quite decent but it
seems that nowadays I've seen this idea
nowadays why just does not advance this
um this is far far more inconvenient
here the computer points out a very good
resource nigeria noise actually didn't
consider that at all the idea being that
this is very much helpful for black
interesting yeah really played a good
game I guess always keeping me under
pressure alright thanks for watching